dude somebody went so hard and trying to
animate this weasel
the posing and the timing and the rhythm
is so clean and clear and interesting is
it what is this is this a movie
thanks to shutter for sponsoring this
video stick around to the end to find
out how you can get a free 30-day trial
hey guys welcome back this is the third
ever episode
it's the fourth ever episode of
animators react we're here with alex
snow he is a 3d character animator
extraordinaire right now he's a
dreamworks he's worked at disney he's
done a lot of movies that you probably
know about let's just hop into it and
let's let's look at some clips cause i
got a lot of questions
oh i want to get played
this movie's with good it's so good
arguably the best toy story i think
everything pixar does is like
masterpiece yeah how do they how do they
freaking knock it out the park every
time i mean it's always story story
story i also think they have a lot of
freedom in their brand just how they
built it
[Music]
this scene is in particular it's one of
my favorite shots i could be wrong but i
think doug sweetland animated it he's
responsible for some of my personal
favorite pixar shots the one of woody
and toy story 2 where he comes out of
the box
[Music]
and the one of sully and monsters inc
where he's like watching what he thinks
is boo getting crutches
[Music]
then this one the posing and the timing
and the rhythm is so clean and clear and
interesting the hat comes off at the
perfect time he catches at the perfect
time it's just so clear how he holds the
rail yeah he uses the
the appeal of the drawings the appeal of
appeal is a is a principle but it really
encompasses every principle so you
mentioned animating principles i gotta
ask are these like things that you'd
learn in school is like a rule sheet
that you guys have next to your desk
like where do these come from so the
principles come from the nine old men
which are like the original animators of
disney milk call is my personal favorite
shir khan best character ever these
principles kind of developed through
experience and experimentation and
there's a list of ten but it's really
off the top of my head and i know i
don't know them because i'm a terrible
animator person
[Laughter]
timing
spacing
arcs
overlap
acting
appeal and however many more i didn't
list
uh but they all you can't do one without
the other and they all kind of build and
so you're always using those things
together to kind of build this
believable and specific thing that's why
i love this shot so much everything is
coming together that's not just a person
climbing to a window that's a toy
climbing to the window it's not just a
toy climbing to the window it's woody
climbing to the window if you did this
with buzz it would be a different shot
or it should be and so having that
character specificity is also something
that takes it to kind of an another
level
[Music]
so i watched toy story 4 recently loved
the movie the thing that really stood
out to me was how there's all these
different characters are animated in
very distinctly different ways you know
woody's basically a rag doll yeah you
know he's animated a certain way but any
of these ventriloquist dummies that are
animated like they're you know basically
hanging from strings where somebody's
holding them by their head and then you
have this like stuntman action figure
which is animated completely differently
almost like you stop motion and then you
have four key which is literally just
animated like somebody's going like this
but like there's so much distinct
physics for each one yeah with keanu
reeves character he's kind of like ken
and barbie like ken was always my
favorite because of those same
limitations it's like it feels like he's
got these specific joints that can only
move i mean how his head stays stable
while he rides around so most shows will
have character leads and so they'll do
tests like acting tests with as they're
developing the rig to find what kind of
simulation and and connectivity works
best for the character and most often
and so there's controls what's called ik
and fk so i hear you mentioned fk and ik
and i just want to clarify the terms for
the audience here so fk stands for
forward kinematics and basically
something like that would be useful if
you're animating like a robot arm where
you're going to animate the bass and you
go from you know a bass joint forwards
and then inverse kinematics is basically
that backwards where you start with
something that's on the end and then
everything else will kind of adjust like
for example if i grab something and i
can want to animate my character to grab
something then i want to like have the
body move and everything kind of reacts
accordingly you know i can place the
hand and then have the inverse
kinematics to drive the rest of the
joint movements
as the body adjusts so they're different
styles of
motion
propagation through your model so you'll
usually you'll find it's kind of that ik
fk through the whole rig they used to be
much more fk driven and now it's much
more of a mix the legs have always been
as far as i've been animating most
likely ik because they are you want that
planted feel you want that to be in the
same place the danger with something
like ik is it's almost not tied to the
body in the same way like a mind putting
his hands on glass
yeah
so with this you're using fk to its most
powerful degree because of the
limitations of the character like it
feels that like rigid
action action-figure-y feel but it's
these differences and the limitations
that make this character so specific so
something like the dummies here in this
scene they have no center of gravity
limitations they can be leaning forwards
and their feet will still drag which is
such a creepy like ghost-like thing it's
like there's invisible hands holding
them up from their back i love like even
when they're running their heads are
sideways and it gives it this feel of
like i'm out of control there's a shot
in ratatouille where he like dodges
under the plate
why it feels like he's out of control is
because his head isn't the driving force
he doesn't know where he's going so by
having it feel like his chest and then
he's like coming after is like what just
happened it feels like someone else is
controlling or someone else is tugging
him on a rope has that exact same dummy
feel like you look like a ventriloquist
right there exactly if you guys enjoy
these shows animators react visual
effects artists react stuntmen react
please consider subscribing to this
channel if you are not it helps us make
the videos more consistent it helps us
know who's out there watching and it
helps youtube know that these videos are
being watched so consider subscribing to
the channel
some folks call this thing here a guitar
funny
this scene is great it's super opposite
of like anything we've talked about
because it's super super subtle it's
also mocap driven mostly i believe the
facial performances are completely
animated and based on the reference they
capture in the scene
it's a moment in the game where
they're kind of reconnecting joel's
messed up as usual and he's kind of like
earning ellie's
love and trust back there's this one
moment where joel he's playing the song
and there you get this kind of push of
the nose followed by the chest these
mechanics you feel him almost
push he's struggling to get this song
out there's this moment where joel's
like brows come up the brows lead the
head up
and it almost feels like a breath but it
also feels like
i just gotta get through this next part
you know like i need her to feel what
i'm feeling and i'm not good at this
there is one moment here that's not as
good arguably i'm sorry you get this
disconnect right right there oh
my eyes go to here and his head goes
forward it feels disconnected i get the
idea of like i want him to feel
insecure and like he's looking away but
the eyes often drive the head it's
almost like like a connection so the
eyes almost catch the head and pull it
and then the head pulls the chest we're
feeling that disconnection here as he
really is like saying something to her
and
and goes
right and you're like
it's weird that he's coming forward
while looking away if you're coming
forward from an acting perspective
you're probably not looking away
internally you're not like shy or you
might come forward and then look away
but it happening at the same time is
what kind of disconnects it ellie
actually does do a thing where she like
leans to the side while watching him but
it feels appropriate because it feels
like she's pulling away well saying well
making eye contact so it's like i'm
embarrassed or like i'm touched or that
you could read that in a few different
good ways that you that you want to
there's just like so much emotion both
last of us and everything naughty dog
does always pushes storytelling
experiences to like a new height
i'm sending you to the cooler burglar
i'm gonna kill you is it what is this a
movie so this is food fight
so food fight is like famous for costing
something like 70 million dollars oh
it was like on hold and off hold forever
and it has like big name people but it's
just like this atrocious
weird
mocappy thing where it seems like it's
just straight data
and there's like barely any facial
animation ever man their eyes don't
track anything they're just pointed
forwards yeah i don't even know if they
have mouth shapes it feels like it's
just a jaw and a body doing things
there's also like horrible character
designs and other things not helping the
situation
so this is a
weasel it looks like a rotisserie
chicken
why is he standing why is he standing
like
it looks so strange that's the closest i
ever thought i'd see a human getting
matching yeah i was like legitimately
impressed yeah
somebody went so hard and trying to
animate this weasel
out of all the characters this weasel
definitely got the most love and this is
the result dude this is weird yeah it
only gets weirder from what i've seen
[Music]
they didn't even bother to like rig the
fingers throughout the characters like
no one's fingers moved this entire time
[Applause]
[Music]
you can see like as soon as they take
off the ground you can't use the mocap
data like everything just goes yeah in
fact i see i see a problem that i've
struggled with which is like if you're
doing a flip you know you need to flip
around the center of gravity of the body
but your pivot point might not
necessarily be there so like you're
spinning the character literally just
rotating the character in space but then
you also have to like do all the fake
physics of it and like they're just
animating this character to move but
like the way the character is moving
from the pivot doesn't line up with the
pivot being at the center of gravity at
all the characters move and fall at
different rates and like that everything
should fall at the same speed objects of
different weight fall at the same speed
the only thing that changes it is their
resistance speed time spacing that's
probably the biggest thing new animators
struggle with people think like fast is
light and slow is heavy sumo wrestlers
are a great reference because it's like
you have to like really throw that
weight up it eases in and then gravity
takes over it comes down fast and then
your body kind of absorbs it where a new
animator would animate it like just all
going slow
and you're like that it feels slow but
it doesn't feel heavy it's the same
thing with like pacific rim you're like
they're big robots they're moving slow i
should animate it slow but it's more
like watching an airplane
fly by and you're like oh look i can run
as fast as an airplane it's like no you
can't that if you put a camera on the
airplane it would be like
right it's going a thousand miles per
hour it's the same thing with pacific
rim to see the scale the camera has to
be so far away the the fist is actually
traveling like
city blocks a second right and so if you
put a camera on the fist you'd be like
right but from far away it's this
but as it gets closer it's going faster
faster faster faster because your
perspective of that object is changing
and your ability to register how fast
it's traveling becomes more accurate
it's understanding those principles in
the real world and and at physics as
much as you can and this movie does
absolutely none of that
frankly my dear i don't give a spam hey
uh if you worked on food fight
please leave a comment tell us what it
was like
we'd love to hear about it also we're
sorry we're sorry
you guys might remember in a previous
episode of vfx artists react we talked
about a series called blood machines
which is this really crazy visually
dense piece of filmmaking that was made
by these french guys in their house
basically it's really unique like it
doesn't really exist for the netflix's
or the youtubes of the world it actually
exists on a relatively unique platform
called shutter which happens to be the
sponsor of today's video shutter has the
largest fastest growing human curated
selection of thrilling and dangerous
entertainment there are new spine
tingling thrillers shocking horrors and
edge of your seat suspense added weekly
shredder has a unique collection of
exclusive and original films and series
horror classics and blockbuster hits and
you can subscribe for 5.99 a month or
56.99 a year you'll have unlimited
access to stream ad free on all of your
favorite devices so if you'd like to
watch blood machines so check out many
of the other cool shows they have you
can try shutter free for 30 days go to
shutter.com that's
shudder.com and use the coupon code
corridor crew thanks shuter once again
for sponsoring this video now back to
the episode
i hope you guys enjoyed that episode i
know i learned so much from you man like
that was really really cool you blew my
mind in so many different ways i would
love to have you back if you have the
time and do an anime episode maybe i
think that'd be like yeah definitely if
people want to find you and follow your
work where could they do that over on
instagram i'm at snowmation or
doubleplus productions on instagram as
well well thank you so much alex really
appreciate you coming out awesome being
here